l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion en
nouvelle lecture du projet de loi
relatif à la prévention d'actes de
terrorisme et au renseignement
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à madame la ministre madame arlette
schiappa ministre chargé de la
citoyenneté
monsieur le président madame monsieur
les rapporteurs madame les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs le gouvernement
ce soir maintient la ligne qui n'a cessé
d'être la sienne depuis 2010 est en
responsabilité garantir l'équilibré
entre efficacité de l'action
antiterroriste et préservation des
libertés individuelles et c'est fort de
cette ligne qui est notre constance que
le gouvernement revient aujourd'hui vers
vous en deuxième lecture
déterminé à défendre des positions qui
ont été mûrement réfléchi travaillé
penser au soutien d'un texte essentiel
pour renforcer l'arsenal législatif en
matière de lutte antiterroriste et
singulièrement s'agissant du suivi des
sortants de prison condamné pour actes
de terrorisme
ce sont des considérations d'efficacité
opérationnelle le pragmatisme de respect
de l'équilibré initial et de recherche
du plus large consensus qui continue à
nous anime et collectivement
je souhaite à cet égard particulièrement
remercié au nom du gouvernement les
membres de la commission des lois du
sénat mais aussi ceux de la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement et de la
mission d'information sur la loi sur le
renseignement
ainsi bien sûr que les rapporteurs pour
la qualité du travail commun mené depuis
plusieurs mois avec le gouvernement y
compris parfois bien sûr avec à
certaines divergences et c'est aussi
l'occasion de vous exprimer le souhait
que ce travail commence fils se
poursuivre tant il est important sur ces
questions que nous puissions agir
ensemble avec responsabilité c'est
l'occasion aussi pour moi de saluer
l'excellence du travail de nos services
de renseignement
nos policiers et nos gendarmes qui
chaque jour font un travail exceptionnel
pour identifier les menaces suivre les
individus dangereux mettre en péril
leur projet meurtrier deuxième lecture
donc après un échec de la commission
mixte paritaire alors même faire
consensus
nous devons toutes et tous nous
féliciter s'est dégagé sur la majorité
des dispositions de ce texte relatif à
la prévention des actes de terrorisme et
au renseignement
une divergence de vue sur le dispositif
de suivi des sortants de prison condamné
pour terrorisme a conduit à cet échec et
je crois que nous la scion et vous le
savez 188 qu'on dernier terroristes
islamistes sortiront de détention d'ici
2025 beaucoup demeurent ancrés dans une
idéologie radicale
ces individus ils constituent ce que
l'on appelle le haut du spectre des
objectifs suivis par les services de
renseignement il présente des enjeux
sécuritaires multiples à la sortie de la
détention prosélytisme menace à court
terme représenter par certains profils
dits impulsif menace à moyen et long
terme relatives à des projets
d'attentats ou encore tentative de
redéploiement vers des zones de djihad à
l'étranger l'expérience acquise au cours
des dernières années nous permet
aujourd'hui d'affirmer que le placement
sous me casse constitue pour ces profils
un outil particulièrement utile et
adapté puisqu'il permet de faciliter la
surveillance d'individus sortant de
prison d'observer leurs relations
habituelles leurs pratiques leurs
activités sur les réseaux sociaux leurs
efforts de réinsertion le cas échéant et
c'est là où la mise en place d'une
surveillance physique ou technique à
plein temps se révèlerait difficile
également ressources en raison parlons
des ressources humaines que cela inspire
est pour ces profils présentant une
dangerosité élevée la limite de 12 mois
se révèle nous le maintenons inadapté
d'ores et déjà un certain nombre de mika
sont arrivés à échéance
19 me casse sont arrivés à échéance
depuis 2010 est alors même que les
services sont en mesure de justifier de
la persistance de la menace constituée
par le comportement de ces individus
c'est pourquoi le projet du gouvernement
votée par l'assemblée nationale prévoir
dans des conditions strictement encadré
un allongement de ces me casse à une
durée de deux ans je rappelle que cet
allongement
il est encadré de garanties fortes qui
permettent de sécuriser la mesure sur le
plan constitutionnel ainsi l'ami cas ce
ne pourrait être prolongée que jusqu'à
24 mois qu'à l'encontre d'individus
condamnés pour des faits de
terrorisme ou à au moins cinq ans de
détention ou trois ans en cas de
récidive
en outre au-delà de douze mois le
renouvellement de la mesure sera soumis
à l'existence d'éléments nouveaux ou de
fait complémentaires en 2018 le conseil
constitutionnel a il est vrai fait de la
limitation à 12 mois l'un des éléments
du bilan de la constitutionnalité des
nickas masi s'est cependant prononcé sur
une population différente et bien plus
large que celle visée par l'amendement
du gouvernement
ainsi été visé de manière générale les
personnes présentant des dix cygnes
avérée de radicalisation y compris ciel
était pas passé à l'acte et n'avait pas
fait l'objet d'une judiciarisation ce
sont donc des cas d'école différents en
revanche le juge constitutionnel n'a pas
été saisie du cas spécifique que nous
traitons des individus ayant fait
l'objet d'une condamnation pour des
faits de terrorisme et qui présente une
différence objective de situations
pouvant justifier des mesures plus
contraignantes
le conseil constitutionnel a indiqué que
l'ami casse ne pouvait se prolonger
indéfiniment
aussi longtemps que durera cette menace
mais le conseil constitutionnel n'a pas
interdit aux législateurs de pouvoir
allonger la durée de la nique à ce pour
les pros chez les plus dangereux dès
lors que la durée de cette mesure
continue d'être borné dans le temps ce
qu'elle est quels sont les éléments que
je tenais une nouvelle fois au nom du
gouvernement à apporter auprès de vous
dans cet hémicycle la modélisation du
gouvernement pour lutter contre le
terrorisme depuis 2010 est elle ne
pourrait être sans le soutien constant
du parlement renforcement des moyens
humains budgétaire est aussi vous dire
ici surtout juridique au profit de
l'ensemble des services de
renseignements des forces de sécurité
des magistrats de l'ensemble des
services de l'état qui mènent ce
difficile combat sans relâche je vous
remercie
merci madame la ministre la parole est
maintenant aux 1 marc philippe daubresse
rapporteur de la commission des lois
monsieur le président madame le ministre
mais ce président de la commission même
là apportant mes chers collègues
chacun bien sûr dans cet hémicycle est
prêt à mettre en place le dispositif le
plus efficace de prévention des actes de
terrorisme et nous voulons nous associer
madame la ministre à lomas que vous
rendez à nos services de police en
général mais de renseignements
particuliers qui sont exemplaires par
leur abnégation mais les moyens pour y
parvenir sont multiples après l'échec de
la commission mixte paritaire le 9
juillet 2021 l'assemblée nationale je
fais le 13 juillet l'examen nouvelle
lecture de ce projet de loi sur les 36
articles que comprenait le projet 19
restaient encore en discussion
l'assemblée nationale a adopté six sont
modifications et confirmé une
suppression à la adopté les deux
articles restants avec des modifications
substantielles par rapport au texte qui
était celui du sénat pour la partie vous
l'avez dit relative au terrorisme
notamment vos articles 2 3 et 5
si nous étions très proches d'un accord
avant cette commission mixte paritaire
l'intransigeance du gouvernement a rendu
inévitable son échec
cette intransigeance et confirmés en
nouvelle lecture alors que les points de
vue s'était fortement rapprochée entre
députés et sénateurs juste avant la cmp
je rappelle que notre principal point de
désaccord porte sur les modalités de
suivi
vous l'avez dit des personnes condamnées
pour des actes de terrorisme sortant de
détention d'accord sur le constat les
dispositifs existants ne permettent pas
d'assurer ce suivi satisfaisait de
manière satisfaisante puisque près de
200 d'entre eux vont sortir et qu'un
quart d'entre eux sont considérés comme
très dangereux est susceptible de
récidive par le parquet nous sommes en
désaccord sur les voies de réponse le
gouvernement l'assemblée nationale
propose vous l'avez dit d'allonger la
durée des micasa deux ans afin d'assurer
la survie la surveillance de ce public
tout en instaurant une mesure judiciaire
qui se concentrerait sur leur
réinsertion nous proposons quant à nous
de remettre la loi votée en juillet
dernier sur le métier en instaurant une
mesure judiciaire à visée non pas
seulement de réadaptation sociale mais
également de surveillance de l'individu
nous étions éventuellement prêt à
envisager une évolution sur les deux
endémique à sa condition de conserver
cette mesure de sûreté qui a une
dimension d'ensemblier nous considérons
en effet que les mesures depuis
judiciaire présente plusieurs avantages
prononcée par un juge elle offre des
possibilités de surveillance plus longue
et potentiellement plus contraignantes à
présent des garanties plus importantes
pour les individus concernés car elles
sont prononcées à l'issue d'une
procédure contradictoire
elles permettent enfin d'associer aux
mesures de surveillance les mesures
sociales
disons à favoriser réinsertion de la
personne
l'assemblée nationale n'a pas souhaité
donner suite à nos multiples
propositions de compromis sur l'article
5 je rappelle que nous en avons fait 12
et que nous avions beaucoup travaillé
face à cette position intransigeante de
la majorité gouvernementale nous vous
proposerons de supprimer les
prolongations des micasa l'article 3
mais d'adopter à l'article 5 une
rédaction qui avait été discutée avec
les députés
préalablement à la cmp il s'agit afin
d'assurer la bonne articulation entre
mesures judiciaires et mesures
administratives de prévoir que lorsque
cette mesure de sûreté comprend des
obligations qui sont similaires à celles
prononcées dans le cas des me casses les
premières ne peuvent entrer en vigueur
que lorsque les seconds sont levés nous
vous proposons également de rétablir le
texte du sénat sur l'article 2 notre
texte permet une caractérisation plus
précise des locaux annexes au lieu de
culte qu'il sera possible de fermer
s'il existe des raisons sérieuses de
penser qu'ils seraient utilisés pour
faire échec à l'exécution de la
fermeture de l de la mesure de fermeture
du lieu de culte dans une perspective de
conciliation avec l'assemblée nationale
nous vous proposons de supprimer la
mention de l'accueil habituel de
réunions publiques étant entendu que les
mesures de police administrative ne
peuvent concerner des lieux privés
cette mention semble satisfaite
voilà sur l'essentiel de la partie
terrorisme et je sais de maintenant la
parole à ma collègue agnès canayer sur
le renseignement bien comme vient de le
dire monsieur le rapporteur la parole
est à madame agnès canayer rapporteur de
la commission des lois
mathieu président madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois
mes chers collègues concernant la partie
renseignements le sénat a eu une comme
priorité de doter les services de
renseignement des moyens adaptés pour
faire face à l'évolution notamment
technologiques mais surtout des
pratiques terroristes et criminels qui
menacent la sécurité intérieure de notre
pays notre travail a été guidée par le
respect des libertés constitutionnelles
en s'assurant notamment de la protection
de la vie privée par un réel encadrement
législatif doublé de contrôle suffisant
en première lecture le sénat avait
abouti à un juste équilibre entre
liberté et sécurité après des
discussions très constructives avec mon
homologue le député loïc est vrai en
hégra ce aux nombreux échanges menés au
sein de la dpr nous étions parvenus à
nous entendre sur la partie relative aux
renseignements
cet accord n'a malheureusement pas
survécu à l'échec de la cmp
en effet les députés ont rétabli l'accès
des services du second cercle pour
l'expérimentation relatives à
l'interception des données satellitaires
mais cet établissement ne constitue pas
pour nous un point de blocage
en effet l'assemblée nationale a précisé
que les services du second cercle
concernés sont ceux dont les missions le
justifie et qui seront déterminés par un
décret en conseil et en prêts a pris
après avis de la cntr dès lors pour nous
les conditions de participation des
services du second cercle nous
paraissent satisfaisante et suffisamment
précises
par contre à l'article 13 les députés
ont supprimé le caractère expérimental
de l'extension du traitement de
l'algorithme aux url prévu par le sénat
jusqu'au 31 juillet 2025
or tant d'un point de vue technique que
du point de vue juridique cette
extension ne nous plaît pas pas possible
sans une expérimentation préalable je
rappelle que
url sont des données de nature mixte qui
relève à la fois des données de côté
connexions et du contenu des
communications et qu'elles font donc
légitimement l'objet d'une protection
renforcée la nécessité d'une
expérimentation avait été soulignée par
la dpr dans son dernier rapport et je
regrette que nous n'ayons pas trouvé
d'accord sur ce point
nous vous proposerons donc de rétablir
la version du sénat à l'article 13
outre des modifications purement
rédactionnelles les députés sont revenus
sur une précision que nous avions
apporté à l'article 15 sur la
conservation des données de connexion
vous savez le régime français a été
nettement remis en cause par la
jurisprudence de la cour de justice de
l'union européenne avec un impact
important
vous le savez sur les enquêtes
judiciaires nous avons souhaité préciser
dans le texte que les catégories de
données conservées par des opérateurs
dans le cadre de leur obligation de
conservation permanente c'est-à-dire les
données relatives à l'identité des
coordonnées de contact et de paiement
des comptes et les adresses ip reste
accessible haute autorité judiciaire
dans le cadre des procédures de
réquisition habituel cette précision
respecte l'arrêt de la cour de justice
de l'union européenne et facilite le
travail des enquêteurs
nous vous proposons donc de le rétablir
enfin le sénat avait adopté deux
amendements rédactionnels sans en
modifier la teneur à l'article 7 portant
sur la communication au service de
renseignement par les autorités
administratives
l'assemblée nationale a adopté un
amendement de fond qui apporte des
garanties supplémentaires
suite à la décision du conseil
constitutionnel rendue le 9 juillet
dernier soit après la cmp qui précise
que les transmission de renseignements
par les autorités administratives se
font de leur propre initiative que ces
données doivent être plus encadrés et
surtout qu'il y à de nouvelles exigences
de traçabilité
ces précisions me semble de nature à
renforcer l'encadrement de la
transmission d'informations par les
autorités administratives aux services
de renseignements je vous propose donc
de ne pas les modifier
à l'inversé députés ont adopté conforme
l'article 19 relative aux archives
protéger notre débat et nos débats
avaient été très approfondie sur ce
sujet en première lecture
nous savons que le dialogue doit se
poursuivre entre les représentants de la
profession les mines
ce ter et les services concernés mais
nous ne sommes pas appelé en rediscuter
dans cette nouvelle lecture
ce pur merci bien merci dans la suite de
la discussion générale
la parole est à notre collègue jean yves
le conte pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains
monsieur le président madame là mais
disent mes chers collègues l'actualité
du renseignement nous montre combien les
outils les plus puissants d'intrusion
peuvent être développées aujourd'hui par
des acteurs privés est aussi utilisée
par eux les nouvelles technologies le
constellation de sanitaires la 5g mais
aussi plus prosaïquement les
applications de téléphone le montre et
cela ira de plus en plus dans cette
direction
il y aura donc un certain paradoxe a
constaté que des opérateurs privés
puissent faire du renseignement et ne
pas habilités en encadrant les services
publics à le faire aussi il y aurait un
certain paradoxe à l'accepter pour les
uns et à ne pas l'accepter pour ceux qui
ont vocation à nous protéger alors que
justement la maîtrise des techniques de
renseignement aujourd'hui est essentiel
pour pouvoir protéger les français
physiquement mais aussi dans leur vie
privée et les débats que nous avons et
les constatations que nous avons sur la
sphère pegasus depuis quelques jours le
montre et c'est bien pour cela qu'il
faut encadrer les services de
renseignement c'est essentiel dans une
société démocratique et de ce point de
vue là la loi de 2015 a constitué une
rupture une rupture avec la création de
la cgtr des moyens donnés au gic qui
permette d'encadrer la manière dont les
techniques de renseignement sont
utilisés par la puissance publique
en france les nouvelles technologies
existent aujourd'hui d'améliorer les
choses d'élargir des choses est ce ce
que propose cette loi et nous soutenons
les propositions de de la rapporteure de
compte tenu de la nature intrusive des
url et nous aurons le débat tout à
l'heure de faire ça en expérimentation
nous devons toutefois regretter et en
particulier compte tenu de
l'actualité que ce texte ne tiennent pas
compte de l'arrêt du 25 mai dernier de
la cndh qui demande un encadrement des
relations avec les services étrangers
parce que la sphère actuelles montrent
que ce qui n'est pas possible à de faire
dans un pays peut être sous traitée
ailleurs et s'il n'ya pas d'encadrement
des échanges
il y a un problème il y a fui et
finalement l'encadrement ne sert à rien
et d'un autre côté si nous mêmes n'avons
pas des services encadré dans leurs
échanges avec l'étranger il ya un
certain nombre de pays de partenaires
proches qui eux ne se conforment à
l'arrêt de la cod h qui ne pourront plus
travailler de la même manière avec nous
c'est donc indispensable sur les
questions de terrorisme les menaces au
levant en afghanistan en libye mais
aussi l'évolution de ces menaces sont
que nous devons continuer à avoir des
outils pour protéger les français
mais nous devons les avoir dans la
conformité à nos valeurs
si nous les changeons alors nous faisons
de donnant victoire aux terroristes
c'est la raison pour laquelle depuis le
début nous le groupe socialiste
considère que la prévention relève du
pouvoir administratif mais que dès que
c'est possible il faut judiciariser de
manière à mettre les éventuelle
privation de liberté sous le contrôle du
juge
et ça s'appuie aussi sur une coopération
importante entre le parquet et les
services administratifs et aussi par la
conviction que les moyens les moyens aux
services de renseignement les moyens de
la police des moyens de l'ensemble de
l'âge de la justice ne remplacerons sont
toujours plus indispensable que les lois
pour donner des moyens et faire en sorte
que les choses que les français puissent
être protégées lenny casse qui sont
particulièrement intrusive sont
peut-être nécessaire et nous avons
plusieurs fois dit que nous n'étions pas
opposés à leur maintien même si nous
avons aussi indiqué que nous souhaitions
un contrôle régulier du parlement et des
votes régulier du parlement si nous les
relations ce n'est pas ce qui a été
retenu par la commission mixte paritaire
même si elle a échoué il ya quand même
un certain nombre de convergences entre
le sénat l'assemblée celle que nous ne
partageons tous nous considérons que sur
cette partie là pour être certain
que les dispositions qui sortiront du
parlement seront conformes aux garanties
que offre notre constitution nous
saisirons le conseil constitutionnel
pour être certain de ne pas avoir de
doute sur le lait le texte qui sortira
du parlement après deux remarques
d'abord sur l'article 15 et à la manière
dont le parlement et le gouvernement
propose de sortir de la difficulté
rencontre que nous rencontrons depuis
l'arrêt de la cour de justice de l'union
européenne sur la question des d'imposer
aux opérateurs de conserver les données
de connexion ce qui en particulier
empêche la justice de faire son travail
et de répondre à aux +2 à près de deux
millions de réquisition judiciaire tous
les ans c'est une crainte importante des
parquets de ne pas être capable de
continuer leur enquête avec la même
fiabilité et la robustesse
compte tenu de cet arrêt de la cour de
justice et il nous semble que l'article
15 proposés sans regarder ce que
faisaient nos partenaires européens qui
sont aussi soumis à cette même
législation à ces mêmes règles sans
regarder si éventuellement à partir du
moment où l'ensemble des pays européens
avait une difficulté sur ce sujet si ce
n'était pas là la règle européenne qu'il
ne fallait changer nous semble un peu
hasardeuse et l'interrogation que j'ai
données que l'intérêt la question que
j'ai posée tout à leur mise de la
justice sur ce point montre que c'est
peut être traitée avec un peu de
désinvolture
alors que pour avoir confiance dans la
justice il faut aussi lui donner des
moyens robuste et fiable
enfin dernier point l'article 19 sur les
archives et là excusez moi mais c'est
scandaleux c'est scandaleux de revenir
aujourd'hui sur le plan législatif alors
que ya eu accord entre la foulée
nationale et sénat c'est adopté conforme
ne pouvons pas présenté d'un moment mais
nous voulons marquer notre absolue
désaccords au sein du groupe pour le
groupe socialiste avec cette méthode qui
consiste à voter aujourd'hui quelque
chose qui changera la base légale qui
fera que l'arrêt du conseil d'état du 2
juillet ne pourra qu'y à annuler les
procédures de déficit les deux
classifications ne sera plus actuelle ce
n'est pas un tissu
car construire l'histoire de notre pays
non pas sur des mythes mais sur la
réalité et donner la possibilité à nos
chercheurs de construire notre récit
national sur la base de la réalité est
essentielle et c'est ce qui ne sera pas
possible
s'il n'est pas possible de déclassifier
un certain nombre de choses nous savons
bien que sur certaines choses qui
peuvent encore dans une activité
opérationnelle
il faut encore protégé mais nous
considérons que la manière avec laquelle
le débat a été mené et ce après ça
aboutit est un réel scandale et c'est la
raison pour laquelle malgré notre accord
sur un certain nombre de points
nous nous abstiendrons sur ce texte
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à franck mais non ville pour
le groupe les indépendants
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
la commission mixte paritaire n'est pas
parvenu à une rédaction commune des 19
articles restent en discussion
je le regrette d'autant plus que
l'exercice a échoué de peu
un compromis avait été pourtant trouvé
sur les objectifs de renseignement ce ne
fut malheureusement pas le cas pour les
autres dispositions notamment les points
d'achoppement portait sur l'articulation
des mesures relatives aux sortants de
prison
en effet les membres de la cmp non pas
diverger sur le principe selon lequel
les sortants de prison condamné pour des
faits de terrorisme doivent faire
l'objet d'un suivi mais plutôt sur la
nature et le contenu ces mesures je
voudrais revenir sur quelques chiffres
que j'ai déjà mentionné à cette tribune
ya peu 469 personnes sont détenues dans
les prisons françaises pour actes
terroristes islamistes 250 300 condamnés
et purgent une peine 162 devrait d'être
libéré dans les quatre prochaines années
et présentent un réel risque de
réitération des faits ce risque nous le
savons tous des pas théorique
ces chiffres ne sont pas équivoque il
faut agir vite pour mieux protéger nos
concitoyens
la question des sorties de prison
illustre de façon emblématique
l'évolution de cette menace de plus en
plus endogène hausse il est de notre
devoir de tout mettre en oeuvre pour
garantir la protection de nos
concitoyens
ce projet de loi est donc primordial
pour à bien des égards
tout d'abord il touche au droit à la
sûreté
il nous permet de tout de lutter avec
plus d'efficacité contre les ennemis de
la france qui veulent nous toucher au
coeur à chaque attaque c'est la
république tout entière qui est atteinte
ensuite ce projet de loi est
indispensable à tous ceux pour tous ceux
dont les activités bien souvent dans
l'ombre et de lutter au quotidien contre
les menaces terroristes le terrorisme
constitue un défi majeur de notre temps
c'est il faut le dire une nouvelle forme
de guerre
chaque jour qui passe nous rappelle à
quel point la menace est omniprésente
prend des formes diverses et variées et
se nourrit des progrès technologiques
nous avons plus nous avons plus que
l'obligation nous avons le devoir d'y
faire face nous devons donner aux
services de renseignement les moyens de
s'adapter à ces nouvelles donnes à la
fois juridiques technologiques et
opérationnelles dans un dans un autre
contexte d'actualité qui nous le
rappellent actuellement si une menace
existe elle doit être prise en compte
s'il existe un vide juridique il doit
être comblé nous avons aussi le devoir
de lever tous risques constitutionnels
et c'est ce que vous avez fait je pense
notamment à la question de l'allongement
de la durée des me des mesures
individuelles de contrôle administratif
et de surveillance à cet égard donc je
félicite véritablement le travail de la
commission du sénat et je fais ce titre
que le sénat ait préféré donc la voie du
renforcement de ces dispositifs de suivi
judiciaire
pour toutes ces raisons donc le groupe
les indépendants votera en faveur de ce
texte modifié par notre collègue
commission il fixe un cadre législatif
dont nous avons besoin pour améliorer la
défense de notre nation contre toutes
les formes de terrorisme et point-ci
garantir la sécurité de nos concitoyens
et comme le disait si justement le
général de gaulle la défense c'est la
première raison d'être de l'état il n'y
peut manquer sans se détruire lui-même
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à guy benarroch pour le
groupe écologiste
merci
du président d'am la ministre madame et
messieurs les rapporteurs ses collègues
notre groupe écologiste solidarité
territoire l'affirmé clairement à de
nombreuses reprises la menace terroriste
existe et nul ne peut prétendre se
désintéresser ou ne pas vouloir doter
les pouvoirs publics des moyens
nécessaires pour y faire face
mais à quel prix au prix de
l'affaiblissement des droits et des
libertés garanties par notre
constitution au prix date est à la
liberté d'aller et venir au secret des
correspondances au secret professionnel
ou encore au droit au respect de la vie
privée et familiale au prix de
l'instauration d'une surveillance
généralisée de nos concitoyens aux
moyens d'ici quatre chaires de captage
des données de communication
satellitaires et de recueil des url au
prix d'un dessaisissement du juge dans
sa mission de protection des libertés
individuelles par la pérennisation dans
notre droit commun du recours intensif à
des procédures administratives relevant
du cadre de l'état d'urgence
à quel prix en outre nous l'avions dit
lors de l'étude de la proposition de loi
justice de proximité réponse pénale
de quels moyens parlons nous quand la
justice pâtit d'un manque de ressources
humaines et matérielles conséquentes qui
l'empêchent de mener à bien sa mission
nous ne cesserons de le marteler le
maigre budget global de la justice
madame la ministre
couplée au manque de personnel sont au
coeur des difficultés de notre système
judiciaire
et si la seule réponse que souhaite
apporter ce gouvernement à la menace
djihadiste est de l'ordre du sécuritaire
alors nous pouvons dès aujourd'hui signé
l'échec de la politique de prévention
d'actes terroristes en france
l'opportunité d'une telle loi est
disproportionnée au regard des besoins
des services de renseignement et plus
encore sous l'angle de son efficience en
termes de réduction du risque terroriste
ce projet de loi qui avait pour but
initial de renforcer notre arsenal pénal
perdre de vue son objectif et tombent
encore une fois dans le piège de toutes
les précédentes lois attentatoires aux
libertés individuelles
il traite par ailleurs du sujet des
archives souhaitant resterai de l'accès
à celle ci notre colère notre collègue
le code vient d'en parler ce qui
contrevient une fois de plus un autre
droit consacré au niveau constitutionnel
en vertu de l'article 16 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen la volonté qu'il cache nous
échappent et nombre de chercheurs
d'historiens d'archiviste et de
politiques d'ailleurs se sont opposés à
cette disposition
aucune réponse de fon est encore
apportée quant au problème réel que
représente la radicalisation
particulièrement en détention à la place
le choix est arbitrairement fait de
s'attaquer aux archives et d'inscrire
dans notre droit commun des procédures
exorbitante du droit commun qui viennent
affaiblir peu à peu notre état de droit
comme nombre de défenseurs des libertés
publiques
nous tirons la sonnette d'alarmé pouvons
nous réellement concevoir une société
qui vit dans un état d'urgence permanent
l'accumulation et la pérennisation des
lois d'exception il s'agit là du 8e
texte de la sorte depuis 2015 n'est
jamais de bon augure
je regrette de surcroît l'absence totale
de concertation préalable autant que je
dénonce ce recours à la procédure
accélérée dans le gouvernement a pris
l'habitude tous deux pris vol parlement
un véritable débat alors s'agirait-il
réellement d'une manoeuvre politicienne
qui consisterait à crac et les
thématiques régaliennes dans le débat
public à l'approché des présidentielles
chacun se fera son opinion sur la
question en ce qui concerne le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoires
nous ne saurions accepter
et comme en première lecture nous
voterons contre ce texte
merci chers collègues la parole est
désormais alain richard
tout le groupe vers des pays
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues nous en
approchons de la conclusion d'un
accomplissement législatif qui
globalement répond aux défis persistants
devenu permanent des menées terroristes
qui continuent à être ourdi dans notre
pays ce projet aboutit donc à consolider
les outils principaux de la surveillance
antiterroriste que sont les me casse
n'est contrôle de lieux de culte les
visites domiciliaires et les périmètres
de protection en à force de d'hésitation
et parfois de réflexion c'est le
contraire de d'assurer maintenant une
conformité constitutionnelle éprouvé ce
projet de loi apporte aussi dans l'état
de discussion de ce maintenant avec donc
une quantité de points qui nous
rassemblent sur l'été nous convergeons
donc un renforcement et une sécurisation
juridique de la technologie des
algorithmes on y introduit également le
dispositif du brouillage des ondes anti
drones agressifs et nous avons
perfectionné la transmission les
méthodes de transmission de données de
sécurité entre services nous apportons
c'est vrai qu'elle est partiel une
réponse au défi légal posés par la
décision de la cour de justice de
l'union européenne relative à la
conservation des données telles
qu'interprétées par le conseil d'état il
ya quelques semaines et nous savons
qu'il nous reste un doute en tout cas
une insatisfaction quant à l'efficacité
persister femmes préserver de la lutte
contre la criminalité donc surtout cela
nous avons un assentiment général je
crois que nous avons fait un travail
de construction législatives
parfaitement correct et qui nous
rassemble sur une base politique large
il subsiste donc un désaccord sur la
méthode de surveillance adaptée à la
situation des anciens condamnés pour
actes de terrorisme
à un certain niveau de gravité et nous
sommes en présence de deux thèses
juridique que je crois l'une et l'autre
assez étayé
mais je m'exprime avec d'autant plus de
mesures sur ce sujet que les uns des
autres
nous avons tout de même connu quelques
mésaventures dans le contrôle
constitutionnel
il me semble donc à la réflexion contenu
comme l'a dit la ministre tout à l'heure
de la spécificité du groupe d'individus
en cause
et au vu de l'expérience prolonger
maintenant des services compétents que
la formule de la mesure administrative
même prolongé à deux ans est adapté à la
situation et elle peut être sécurisé et
nous verrons bien dans quelques semaines
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
défendrons cette formule là aux côtés du
gouvernement met donc sur l'ensemble
c'est sur ce point que je veux insister
en concluant nous avons me semble-t-il
fourni à la l'étape et donc la société
française des outils de protection et
des outils de d'anticipation de la
menace terroriste qui sont je crois
maintenant de bonnes qualités et je le
fais bien sûr en m'associant ascom
conclure que la gueule dans la
discussion à un hommage et un soutien
moral particulier à tous les personnels
qui sont engagés dans la prévention du
terrorisme
merci merci chers collègues la parole
est maintenant à maryse carrère où le
groupe rdse
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
madame est aimé et mesdames et
rapporteur madame insu le rapporteur
pardon chers collègues
d'abord j'aimerais dire mon regret que
sur un projet de loi abordant des
thématiques si fondamentale notre
parlement ne soit pas parvenu à
s'accorder sur un texte commun je le
regrette d'autant plus que sur de
nombreux points nous partons d même
constat le premier est celui de la
nécessité légale comme cela largement
été souligné au cours de la navette
à défaut d'une intervention du
législateur bon nombre de dispositions
du code de la sécurité intérieure issus
notamment de la loi s'ils arriveront à
échéance en 2021
le second est bien entendu l'objet de
toutes ces lois qui consiste à répondre
à la menace terroriste et notamment aux
risques que représentent la sortie de
détention dans les prochaines années
deux détenus condamnés pour des faits en
lien avec le terrorisme
car ce point spécifique doit faire
l'objet d'une réponse législative en
raison de la particulière dangerosité
présentés par ces détenus et pour
lesquels le risque de récidive est
significativement élevé et c'est ici que
se trouve l'une des raison du désaccord
de notre parlement sur cette article 5
du projet qui vise à instituer un
dispositif de suivi des personnes
condamnées pour des actes de terrorisme
de son côté l'assemblée nationale tient
sa position suivant laquelle il
reviendrait au tribunal de l'application
des peines d'ordonner des mesures
judiciaires de prévention et de la
récidive terroristes et de réinsertion
ce dispositif aurait pour singularité de
ne contenir que des obligations tendant
à la réinsertion des individus concernés
laissant ainsi à d'autres mesures les me
casse prévis prévu à l'article 3 du
projet le soin d'assurer un contrôle
administratif et de surveillance
notre chambre quant à elle prévoyait
donc une mesure de nature administrative
et dont le contenu serait mixte temps
d'accompagnement à la réinsertion que de
surveillance susceptibles d'être
davantage contraignantes
de ce point de vue donc la position du
sénat paraissait cohérente et claire
dans sa mise en oeuvre et je crois que
l'argument n'était pas qu'accessoire il
compte pour que notre droit fassent
preuve de clarté
face à l'épreuve que lui impose le
terrorisme toutefois notre commission a
montré sa capacité de compromis en
adoptant lors de ce nouvel examen
une version remaniée du texte et
soucieuse de l'articulation des mesures
administratives et de la nouvelle mesure
judiciaire qui semblait préoccupé le
gouvernement et l'assemblée nationale
dans ces conditions la disposition
sénatoriales offre des garanties
suffisantes au regard de la finalité à
atteindre et surtout elle ne devrait pas
faire l'objet d'une censure
constitutionnelle ce qui je le rappelle
est l'une des raisons pour laquelle nous
devons encore nous réunir sur ces
questions en dernier lieu j'aimerais
redire notre inquiétude s'agissant de
l'article 19 du projet qui vient fixer
le régime juridique de la
communicabilité applicables aux archives
intéressant la défense nationale notre
groupe avait défendu des amendements
afin de proposer des solutions que nous
considérions plus adapté hélas ils n'ont
pas été adoptés et il y as insidieux de
regretter que demeure le sentiment d'une
minimisation des enjeux liés à ces
sujets toutefois malgré ce dernier point
groupe rdse se prononcera
majoritairement en faveur de ce texte
je vous remercie bien merci chers
collègues la parole est maintenant à la
présidente eliane assassi pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes
monsieur le président madame et monsieur
le rapporteur de ce président la
commission des lois bahaa mme la
ministre
en abordant cette nouvelle lecture d'un
texte aux mesures qui nous sont
désormais hélas plus que familières je
dois vous avouer l'inquiétude doublé
d'amertume que nous éprouverons ça de
notre coupe nous qui comme d'autres
sommes mobilisés pour lutter contre le
terrorisme et le risque d' acte
terrorisme dans notre pays mais je
voudrais dire aussi au delà de notre
pays ce projet de loi s'inscrit à la
suite d'une multiplication des lois
sécuritaires dérogatoire au droit commun
voter sans véritable évaluation
préalable des dispositifs existants de
leur nécessité de leur efficacité en
votant ce projet de loi mais chers
collègues vous pérenniser les
dispositifs issus de la loi sylt
dispositifs semblables à des
assignations à résidence et à des pros
perquisition contrôlé par
l'administration qui contournant la
procédure judiciaire et les droits de la
défense présente des conséquences
particulièrement lourde pour les
personnes visées jugé sur des motifs
flou de dangerosité tels que les vicas
un des points d'achoppement ayant
conduit à l'échec de la cmp
mais madame la ministre madame et
monsieur les rapporteurs vous êtes
pourtant d'accord sur la philosophie
globale de ce genre de mesures est en
réalité quelle que soit l'issue et les
micros aménagements sur lesquels vous
vous entendez en pérennisant toutes ces
mesures vous fait le choix d'opérer un
tournant radical en matière de police
administrative inspiré par un principe
de précaution incompatible avec nos
principes démocratiques fondées sur un
droit pénal est d'interprétation stricte
concernant la partie renseignement ce
projet de loi consacre ce qui émerge est
déjà dans la loi de juillet 2015
relatives aux renseignements qui avait
été déférée devant le conseil
constitutionnel par françois hollande
lui-même
l'extension du champ des activités du
renseignement et la législation des
techniques de surveillance intrusif tout
en maintenant à distance l'autorité
judiciaire
avec donc l'ensemble de ces techniques
le gouvernement se dote d'un arsenal de
surveillance de masse pourtant je vous
le redis nos concitoyennes et
concitoyens ne veulent ni renoncer à
leur liberté individuelle ni échangé
leur vie privée contre un état
sécuritaire sans faille illusoire nous
nous interrogeons toujours sur l'utilité
de ces mesures de durcissement de
l'arsenal répressif et administratifs
relatifs à la lutte contre le terrorisme
alors même que notre législation en la
matière et déjà substantiels et que nous
avons appris par ailleurs
à la lecture d'un article d'un journal
du soir comme on dit faisant état d'un
rapport qui a fait état d'un rapport
confidentiel du gouvernement remis aux
membres de l'adedy de la dpr sur la
surveillance numérique que l'utilisation
des algorithmes les boîtes noires
n'avaient permis d'atteindre aucun
objectif opérationnel alors que vous
nous expliquer en parallèle que toutes
les mesures prises en matière de
renseignement sont absolument efficace
et nécessaire pour le travail de nos
services de renseignement
je le redis ici vous considérons pour
notre part que s'il y a lieu de réformer
le renseignement c'est surtout pour
accroître ses ressources humaines et non
le recours irrationnelle et
déraisonnable à des techniques de
surveillance massive qui n'ont
l'actualité nous le démontre qu'ils
n'ont jamais fait des preuves de leur
efficacité en matière de lutte contre le
terrorisme
pour toutes ces raisons auxquelles je
rajoute l'article 19 qui a trouvé un
accord en cmp mais dont nous persistons
à dire qu'il tourne le dos à la
communauté des historiens des
scientifiques et des archives
pour toutes ces raisons donc et des
archivistes pardon pour toutes ces
raisons donc je vous réaffirme ici et
notre opposition déterminée à ce projet
doit et nous argumenteront de nouveau
cette position en défendant quelques
amendements sur les articles encore en
discussion qui nous semblent les plus
problématiques sur merci merci la parole
maintenant à philippe bonnecarrère pour
l'union centriste
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre je suis président
de la commission madame le rapporteur
mais sur rapporteur et sa collègue
la france fait face depuis 2015 à de
nombreuses attaques terroristes
certaines d'origine endogène perpétrés
par des personnes se radicalisant sur le
territoire national outre le risque
djihadistes les services de
renseignement s'inquiètent de
l'émergence de radicalité multiforme
politique religieuse sur les listes ou
encore conspirationnistes face à ces
menaces plusieurs textes de loi ont
permis d'assurer la sécurité de nos
concitoyens tout en garantissant leurs
droits et libertés garantis par la
constitution
il s'agit vous le savez tous chers
collègues de la loi relative aux
renseignements 2015 et de la loi dite
sylt de 2017
le présent projet de loi vise à adapter
notre droit à la menace terroriste en
apportant une réponse légale et
proportionnées aux menaces auxquelles
nous continuons de faire face
aujourd'hui
le texte entend ainsi pérenniser nous
avions même envisager le cdh avait même
envisagé pérenniser plus tôt et
d'adapter certaines mesures de la lutte
anti terroriste qui avait été introduite
à titre expérimental dans notre droit
par la loi sylt comme la fermeture
administrative des de culte des mesures
de surveillance ou encore en
renforcement des pouvoirs de police
administrative
il crée de plus une mesure judiciaire de
réinsertion sociale antiterroriste et
renforce la loi sur le renseignement
2015 tout ceci a été largement expliqué
par mes prédécesseurs
la mise en oeuvre de l'ensemble de ces
mesures a été évalué dans le cadre d'une
mission de la commission des lois qui
s'est inscrit dans le moyen terme et à
démontrer l'utilité opérationnel pour
l'autorité administrative ainsi que le
caractère finalement complémentaires
entre l'intervention d'autorités
administratives et l'intervention de
l'autorité judiciaire ce qui n'était pas
forcément acquis initialement
aussi réuni ce matin hier matin par dans
notre commission des lois a examiné le
rapport de nos collègues madame canayer
monsieur daubresse dont je me réussit
conjointement salué le travail
nous regrettons bien sûr comme les
collègues qui se sont exprimés en moi
comme l'a fait également diverses
reprises présidents des commissions des
lois que la cmp n'est plus aboutir sur
ce texte
c'est dommage même si l'objectif était
du moins notre sens atteignable
l'article 3 du projet de loi visant à
prolonger la durée maximale des mesures
individuelles dit me casse à 24 mois été
modifié par le sénat en créant une
mesure de sûreté prononcée du sud
détention de la personne qui comportait
des obligations tente d' accompagnement
à la réinsertion que de surveillance
concernant l'article 5 le sénat avait
créé une mesure de sûreté prononcée à
l'issue de la détention des personnes
qui comportait des obligations d'
accompagnement à la réinsertion et des
mesures de surveillance là également
or l'assemblée nationale est semble-t-il
le gouvernement n'ont pas souhaité aller
au delà des obligations de réinsertion
qu'ils avaient adoptée en première
lecture en réintégrant les articles 3 et
5 dans leur intégralité
pourtant modifié par le sénat
l'assemblée nationale a pris la
responsabilité de ne pas souhaiter un
accord entre nos deux chambres et en
définitive
l'assemblée nationale n'a conservé que d
apport modeste du sénat essentiellement
la suppression de l'article 4 bis qui
pose effectivement des questions en
matière de droit ont recours
juridictionnel effectif
en définitive en conclusion nous
constatons principalement trois points
de divergence entre nos deux chambres
l'extension à 24 mois démis cas ce que
notre commission avait supprimé au
regard du moins dans sa durée et au
regard des interrogations fortes qui
demeure quant à la constitutionnalité de
la mesure au regard de la première
appréciation qui avait été celle du
conseil constitutionnel l'article 5
deuxième point de divergence que la
commission avait modifié
pour prévoir la également la possibilité
prendre ces temps des mesures de
surveillance que des mesures de
réinsertion et enfin l'article 13 pour
lequel la commission a retenu que les
incertitudes tant techniques que
juridiques liés à l'atteinte aux
libertés que représente la possibilité
d'utiliser des url parmi des données
traitées par algorithmes impose de
rendre cette extension expérimental ce
qui entre parenthèses ou accessoirement
permettrait aussi de vérifier la
faisabilité technique de ceux ci qui
n'est peut-être pas tout à fait acquise
sur ces trois points
vous observerez que deux d'entre eux
avaient fait l'objet de décisions du
conseil constitutionnel décision dont
nous avions retenu que une prudence
particulière était une nécessaire el
aricha relisez il ya quelques secondes
chacune des deux assemblées avaient pu
recevoir quelques observations dans cet
exercice sur le troisième point ce ne
sont pas des décisions du conseil
constitutionnel qui sont notre
préoccupation essentielle mais plutôt
les décisions des cgu et celle du
conseil d'état c'est clairement le
problème de conventionalité chacun ici
dans cet hémicycle connaît les efforts
remarquables du conseil d'état pour
éviter le conflit entre droit interne et
droit européen pourtant avait du mal à
imaginer comment tel pourrait être le
chemin de crête pour employer une
formule maintenant classique et trouver
une convergence entre les deux rois la
solution avait été trouvée et il ne nous
semble pas forcément très opportun de
remettre ceci en corse
tout ceci montre que la rédaction
retenue par notre assemblée présenté de
nombreux avantages et le groupe des
sénateurs russes et votre a donc en
faveur du projet de loi
dans la version issue des travaux de
notre commission des lois je vous en
remercie merci chers collègues aient
maintenant la parole à catherine di
folco pour le groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois madame monsieur les rapporteurs
chers collègues
alors on essaie on nous évaluons la
dangerosité du logiciel pegasus sur
notre sécurité nationale nous abordons
l'ultime lecture de ce projet de loi
relatif à la prévention d'actes de
terrorisme et au renseignement
après l'échec de la commission mixte
paritaire du 9 juillet un échec fort
regrettable tant l'accord était
atteignable suite aux discussions
constructives entre les rapporteurs de
l'assemblée nationale et nos deux
rapporteurs spécialistes de ces sujets
agnès canayer membres de la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement et marc
philippe daubresse qui assure le suivi
et l'évaluation
depuis trois ans de la loi sylt comment
expliquer cet échec alors que nous
partageons avec nos collègues députés et
le gouvernement
le constat selon lequel nous ne
disposons pas d'outils techniques et
juridiques suffisants pour lutter contre
le terrorisme
ce texte avait vocation à combler ses
carences je tiens à saluer la position
de la commission des lois du sénat qui
n'a pas choisi de présenter une motion
tendant à opposer une question préalable
mais de poursuivre la discussion de ce
texte
en effet un certain nombre de
modifications apportées par le sénat ont
été retenue par la cmp et notamment sur
le volet renseignements notre collègue
rapporteur agnès canayer et son
homologue à l'assemblée nationale loïc
kervran étaient parvenus à un accord sur
un grand nombre d'articles afin de
donner aux services de renseignement les
moyens de lutter contre les nouvelles
menaces
pour cette dernière lecture notre
rapporteur a également accepté les
ajustements opérés par l'assemblée
nationale à l'article 7 en matière de
communication d'informations aux
services de renseignement par les
autorités administratives à la suite
d'une décision du conseil
constitutionnel elle a cependant tenu à
réintroduire l'expérimentation du
traitement des url par l'algorithme et
nous la suivons dans cette voie de
prudence les rapporteurs ont tenté de
trouver un accord en proposant des
solutions acceptables
il s'avère que leur volonté d'aboutir à
un compromis c
heurtée à l'intransigeance du
gouvernement celui-ci ne semble pas
apprécier à sa juste valeur l'expertisé
de notre haute assemblée et surtout sa
détermination à apporter de vraies
réponses robuste efficace pour faire
face aux menaces qui gangrène la
sécurité de nos concitoyens
alors quels sont les principaux sujets
qui cristallise les désaccords entre nos
deux assemblées
nous les rôles vont dans le volet
prévention du terrorisme domaine ô
combien préoccupant à l'article 2 nous
considérons que la formulation retenue
par les députés pour définir les lieux
annexes au lieu de culte est
insuffisamment précises et comporte un
risque constitutionnel qui fragilise le
dispositif
en effet les députés prévoit que ces
lieux soient définis comme des locaux
dépendant du lieu de culte
alors que nous tenons à préciser qu'il
s'agit des locaux gérés et exploités ou
financer directement ou indirectement
par une personne physique ou morale
gestionnaire du lieu de culte
nous considérons que la fermeture de ses
locaux annexes permettrait de lutter
contre le phénomène de déport de
certains prédicateurs qui utilisent ces
lieux pour échapper aux mesures de
police administrative
ce que souligne à notre rapporteur
maquille daubresse dans son rapport
d'information sur le suivi de la loi
sylt en février 2020 mais notre
divergence majeure à l'origine de
l'échec la cmp porte sur les articles 3
et 5
nous l'avions déjà bien perçues lors de
la première lecture puisque vous aviez
déposé madame la ministre des
amendements pour rétablir le texte de
l'assemblée nationale
nous ne sommes pas favorables à
l'allongement de la durée des me casse
faut-il rappeler une fois de plus la
décision du conseil constitutionnel qui
a considéré que compte tenu de leur
rigueur les me casse ne seraient excédés
de manière continue ou non une durée
totale de 12 mois j'ai du mal à
comprendre pourquoi les députés le
gouvernement ne comprennent pas cet
arbitrage et s'entête à vouloir passer
leur durée à 24 mois et ce malgré les
arguments madame la ministre vous avez
développé lors de votre intervention en
début de séance
nous tenons nous soutenons nos
rapporteur qui ont réintroduit à
l'article 5 la proposition de loi du
président buffet adopté par le sénat en
mai dernier créant une mesure judiciaire
de
suivi et de surveillance cette dernière
semble constituer une voie juridiquement
plus adapté que la proposition initiale
du gouvernement reprises en nouvelle
lecture par l'assemblée nationale
elle offre des possibilités de
surveillance plus longue plus
contraignantes et permet d'associer aux
obligations de surveillance des mesures
sociales de réinsertion cette mesure
reprend le principe du dispositif adopté
par le parlement en juillet 2020
instaurant un régime de sûreté à
l'encontre des sortants de prison
condamné pour terrorisme tout en y
apportant les aménagements nécessaires
pour répondre aux objections du conseil
constitutionnel elle constitue selon
nous la voie à suivre pour répondre à
cette problématique d'une importance
toute particulière
ces dispositions nous paraissent être
les plus efficaces et les plus
respectueuses des libertés
tout au long de l'examen de ce projet de
loi nous rapporterons veiller à assurer
un équilibre entre les mesures de
sécurité et le respect des libertés
constitutionnelles l'enjeu de ce texte
est majeur il faut renforcer notre
arsenal législatif pour assurer la
protection de nos concitoyens qui
aspirent à vivre dans un état de droit
en toute sécurité
nous pensons que le texte de l'assemblée
nationale ne répond pas complètement à
ses enjeux c'est pourquoi nous sommes
satisfaits que le sénat imprime sa
marque et réaffirme sa volonté de
fermeté d'efficacité mais aussi
d'humanité les membres du groupe les
républicains voteront le texte proposé
par le rapporteur
après l'échec d'un accord hier sur le
projet de loi relatifs au respect des
principes de la république
les divergences fondamentales
d'aujourd'hui constitue un nouvel acte
manqué pour lutter contre le séparatisme
et le terrorisme islamiste et nous
pouvons le regretter je vous remercie de
votre attention
bien merci chers collègues la discussion
générale est close madame la ministre
mes chers collègues afin de permettre à
la commission des lois de se réunir pour
examiner les amendements déposés sur ce
texte je vais suspendre la séance
monsieur le président de la commission
de combien de temps pensez-vous avoir
besoin merci monsieur le président une
quinzaine de minutes
je voudrais informer si vous me le
permettez les membres de la commission
des lois que nous ne retrouverons salle
à 120 qui est juste à proximité de
l'hémicycle bien une quinzaine de
minutes donc je vais suspendre la séance
et elle sera reprise à 22h10 aucun la
séance est suspendue
bien la séance et reprise nous passons
la discussion du texte de la commission
je mets aux voix l'article 1er bis qui
et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté je mets aux voix l'article 2
qui est pour et contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté à l'article 3 l'amendement
numéro 15 présenté par un président à ça
si oui merci monsieur le président donc
cet article 3 procès d'un renforcement
du régime d me casse déjà
particulièrement attentatoire aux
libertés publiques et qui avait été mise
en place à titre expérimental et avec
clause de revoyure
étant donné leur caractère
particulièrement exorbitant du droit
commun je ne vais pas revenir ici sur ce
que sont les mic à chacune et chacun le
sait comme chacun chacune et chacun 6
également qu'une personne faisant
l'objet d'une me casse peut se voir
imposer deux séries d'obligations
alternative d'une part l'assignation
géographique et l'obligation pointage
auprès des services de police ou des
unités gendarmerie et d'autre part
l'interdiction de paraître dans certains
lieux et le signalement de tout
déplacement à l'extérieur d'un périmètre
défini dans les décadents les deux cas
le ministre de l'intérieur peut
également prononcé une interdiction
d'entrer en relation avec une ou
plusieurs personnes ainsi qu'une
obligation de déclarer son domicile
alors jusque là la durée des me casse
est strictement encadrée puisque cela a
été dit celles ci ne sont renouvelables
que dans la limite d'une durée cumulée
de douze mois et qu'au delà de six mois
les des éléments nouveaux ou
complémentaires sont requis pour les
prolonger alors prétendant que pour des
profils présentant une dangerosité
élevée de la limite de 12 mois se révèle
inadapté
le gouvernement et la majorité ont
souhaité rétablir le tijd la majorité
gouvernementale pardon on souhaitait
rétablir le texte de l'assemblée
nationale qui prévoyait un possible
allongement une durée de 24 ans
précisant que si le conseil
constitutionnel a fait de la limitation
à 12 mois un des éléments du bilan de la
constitutionnalité de l'amicale
il n'a pas été saisie de la différence
objective de situation entre les
personnes radicalisés n'ayant pas été
condamné pour des faits en lien avec le
terrorisme et celles ayant fait l'objet
d'une condamnation
alors pour notre part nous restons
convaincus que comme l'exprimé le
conseil constitutionnel dans le
commentaire de sa décision
quelle que soit la gravité de la menace
qui justifie une telle mesure de police
administrative ne peut se prolonger
aussi longtemps que dure cette menace
c'est sur la base de tout cela que nous
demandons la suppression de cet article
bien merci chers collègues je vais
demander l'avis de la commission
alors il s'agit d'un amendement de
suppression qui a déjà été débattu en
précédente lecture
nous avons expliqué qu'il y avait des
mesures utiles dans les compléments qui
sont apportées dans cet article 3 pour
les mic a semé nous l'avons réécrit
justement le limitant à un an pour les
mêmes raisons parce que nous partageons
votre analyse sur la constitutionalité
donc avis défavorable madame la ministre
madame la sénatrice celle ci je voudrais
vous dire que le gouvernement est bien
sûr opposés à la suppression de
l'article 3 comme il est d'ailleurs à la
suppression des dispositions du code de
sécurité intérieure qui sont relatives
aux me casse nous considérons que
l'article 3 de ce projet de loi il
apporte plusieurs ajustements au mic
assange doit permettre une plus grande
efficacité notamment pour ce qui
concerne le fait de pouvoir prononcer
une interdiction temporaire de paraître
pour les personnes placées sous me casse
au titre de l'article l 228 si réd 2 du
code de la sécurité intérieure donc
celles qui sont en outre soumises à une
obligation de ne pas quitter un
périmètre déterminé pour ces personnes
une telle interdiction de paraître n'est
aujourd'hui pas possible
cette mesure ne peut pas être prononcées
qu'à l'égard des personnes astreintes
aux obligations les plus légères or il
peut arriver que se tienne au sein du
périmètre au sein duquel la personne est
astreinte à résider des événements
ponctuels exposé par leur ampleur ou par
leurs circonstances particulières un
risque de menaces terroristes je pense
par exemple un procès des auteurs
d'actes de terrorisme qui aura lieu au
tribunal judiciaire de paris auquel une
personne placée sous me casse est
astreinte à résider à paris pourrait
alors se rendre en toute légalité
lorsque sept
situation se présente actuellement il
est nécessaire de modifier le régime
sous lequel est placé la personne pour
le placer sous le régime de l'article l
228 irait 4 du code de la sécurité
intérieure qui permet de prononcer une
interdiction de paraître
mais dans ce cas la personne n'est plus
astreintes à résider au sein d'un
périmètre de résidence donc elle peut le
quitter sans encourir aucune poursuite
pénale
la mesure qui est proposé dans l'article
3 elle corrige cette anomalie en
permettant de cumuler l'astreinte à
résidence dans un périmètre déterminé et
l'interdiction de paraître dans un lieu
précis
au sein de ce périmètre dans lequel se
tient un événement particulièrement
exposées à raison soit de son ampleur
soit des circonstances particulières ou
du risque de menace terroriste
l'article 3 il permet aussi de renforcer
l'efficacité de l'obligation de déclarer
son domicile en imposant à la personne
de fournir le justificatif de domicile
et enfin que les mesures en cours à la
date de promulgation de la loi dont le
terme surviendrait moins de sept jours
après cette promulgation demeurent sans
vigueur pour une durée supplémentaire de
7 jours si les procédés à la
notification de leur renouvellement au
plus tard le lendemain de la publication
de la loi dans un objectif vraiment très
concret cet allongement du dr époux
enfin la nécessité de procéder au
renouvellement de nombreuses mesures qui
seront en cours à la date d'entrée en
vigueur de la loi et qui seraient
susceptibles d'être déféré au juge pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons le
gouvernement est défavorable à votre
amendement je m'excuse d'avoir été long
je le serai moins pour les prochaines
réponse puisque je crois que nous en
avons déjà largement débattue
précédemment merci merci madame la
ministre donc deux avis défavorables je
vais soumettre l'amendement ou voix qui
est pour cet amendement qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté je
soumets aux voix l'article 3 qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté
article 5 amendements numéro 1 de
monsieur benachenhou président cet
article est probablement celui qui a
cristallisé le plus d'opposition
il reprend en effet les dispositions de
la proposition de loi instaurant des
mesures de sûreté à l'encontre des
auteurs d'infractions terroristes à
l'issue de leur peine
ce que qui a été censuré par le conseil
constitutionnel dans sa décision du 7
août 2020 auparavant le conseil d'état
s'était également interrogé sur
l'utilité d'une telle mesure de sûreté
et on peut lire dans son avis du 23 juin
2020 ouvrez les guillemets la
surveillance judiciaire de personnes
dangereuses condamné pour crime ou délit
permet l'application de presque toutes
les mesures de la proposition de loi
en effet de nombreuses mesures de notre
code pénal permettent d'ores et déjà
d'assurer le suivi post détention on
peut notamment citer le suivi socio
judiciaire prévu article 136 36,1 à 131
36 8 du code pénal la mesure de
surveillance judiciaire prévue aux
articles 7 123 29 et suivants du code de
procédure pénale ou encore le suivi post
libération prévue à l'article 7 121 2 du
code de procédure pénale
si nous prenons très au sérieux la
nécessité de prévenir la commission
d'actes à caractère terroriste
la gravité de ses actes ne dispense pas
d'apprécier la stricte nécessité des
mesures prévues or en l'état la présente
disposition par ailleurs d'application
rétroactive
je le souligne porte une atteinte
excessive aux libertés individuelles
c'est en tout cas notre avis est celui
de notre groupe écologie solidarité
territoire qui s'oppose à la mise en
place de cette nouvelle mesure de sûreté
nous regrettons également que ne soient
pas prises en compte la situation des
prisonniers de droit commun qui se
radicalise au cours de leur détention
pour toutes ces raisons nous demandant
la suppression du prêt soit parti merci
chers collègues avis de la commission
sur cet amendement
il s'agit à nouveau d'un amendement de
suppression qui est contraire à la
position de la commission d'autant donc
d'autant qu'il supprime le suivi
judiciaire qui est précisément le point
nodal de notre position sénatoriales et
je redis à monsieur benarroch que nous
nous sommes inscrits dans
après arrêt du conseil constitutionnel
dans la voix 4 assez justement le
conseil constitutionnel pour rendre
constitutionnel mesures de sûreté dont
avis défavorable merci madame la
ministre
avis défavorable égal en se faisant bien
donc un double avis défavorable je vais
soumettre ou voir l'amendement qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient qu'il
n'ait pas adopté
je soumets au voile article 5 qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté article 6 l'amendement numéro 16
madame grès aux mains merci monsieur
président l'article 6 autorise la
communication au préfet et à certains
services du renseignement des caractères
des données à caractère personnel issu
du fichier relatif au suivi des
personnes en soins psychiatriques sans
consentement au psy oued
lorsqu'un patient représente une menace
grave pour la sécurité l'ordre public à
raison de sa radicalisation à caractère
terroriste
le décret du 6 mai 2019 au touriste déjà
l'interconnexion de ce fichier option
web avec le fichier des signalements
pour la prévention de la radicalisation
à caractère terroriste
il s'agit donc avec cet article d'une
nouvelle fuite en avant vers l' amalgame
entre folie et terrorisme et qui
privilégie la logique sécuritaire sur la
logique sanitaire
cette extension du nombre de personnes
ayant accès à une information médicale
contrevient au principe du droit au
respect à la vie privée et au secret des
informations médicales comme l'indiquent
le syndicat de la magistrature la lutte
antiterroriste haute et d'un arsenal
législatif pléthorique continue à servir
de prétexte à la création de toutes
sortes de dispositifs exorbitants tél
tel le fichage et le traçage des
personnes atteintes de troubles mentaux
sans qu'aucune corrélation n'était
établi entre radicalisation à caractère
terroriste et troubles psychiatriques
par la droite lignée des textes sur les
responsabilités pénales et des
mouvements de l'opinion publique sur le
sujet
ce texte vient entériner l'idée que même
les fous doivent être jugés et davantage
encore et plus sévèrement c'est possible
si leur passage à l'acte via se
cristalliser autour de la question du
terrorisme islamique nous pensons notre
côté que ce débat n'est pas la hauteur
de l'enjeu et nous y reviendrons lorsque
le gouvernement nous présentera son
projet de loi sur l'irresponsabilité
pénale
pour l'heure nous vous proposons de
supprimer cette tactique dont la teneur
devrait être éclairées par des travaux
divers et pluraliste pour l'instant
inexistant merci merci chers collègues
avis de la commission il s'agit d'un
nouvel amendement de suppression nous
avions déjà argumenté en première
lecture pour expliquer que au contrat il
n'y avait pas de notre point de vue d'
amalgame entre psychiatrie et terrorisme
et qu'on pouvait trouver une voie
intéressante pour améliorer le
dispositif existant donc avis
défavorable madame la ministre
mais magie monsieur le président mais ma
vie donc un double avis défavorable jeu
sous l amendement aux voix qui pour qui
et contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adoptée je soumets au voile article 6
qui et pour qui contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté
article 7 d'abord l'amendement numéro 2
de monsieur benarroch présenté par mme
benarroch mes recettes
c'est un amendement de suppression via
sur le présent article
en fait acte la fin du principe selon
lequel les renseignements ne peuvent
être utilisées pour des finalités autres
que celles qui motivent la procédure de
surveillance
en effet il prévoit la transmission de
renseignements entre services étant par
là même la communication d'informations
aux services de renseignements je vais
le dire clairement cet article est
attentatoire aux libertés publiques en
permettant à des services de contourner
les restrictions quant à l'usagé des
dispositifs de surveillance la fin de
ceux passibles de finalisation
contrevient au droit au respect à la vie
privée de même l'absence de contrôles
préalables aux mesures de surveillance
est problématique
l'article 7 s'inscrit de ce fait dans la
longue liste des dispositions poussant à
la 18
initialisation du contrôle en matière de
sécurité intérieure c'est pourquoi il
interroge fortement quant à la
traçabilité et à la durée de
conservation de ces informations une
fois transmises l' équilibre à trouver
entre le maintien de l'ordre public et
le respect des libertés publiques n'est
pas atteint donc notre groupe propose la
suppression de ce présent article 7
merci à vis de la commission d'amm
l'arpenteur oui merci monsieur le
président nous émettrons un avis
défavorable sur cet amendement de
suppression de l'article 7 car nous
considérons que l'article 7 mai dans
place à un équilibre satisfaisant pour
la transmission de renseignements aux
services de renseignement et entre
services de renseignement et des
contrôles internes et externes suffisant
pour assurer la garantie du respect des
libertés d'autant que cet article a été
renforcée par l'assemblée nationale pour
le rendre conforme avec la décision du
conseil constitutionnel du 9 juillet
dernier à vis du gouvernement madame la
ministre est favorable monsieur le
président bien double avis défavorable
donc je vais soumettre cet amendement
voix qui et pour qui et contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
maintenant trois amendements discussion
commune le premier présenté par monsieur
le comte
mais c'est le président madame et amis
disent mes chers collègues il est bien
logique que les informations circulent
entre les services de renseignement
toutefois lorsque à une information a
été recueillie par une technique de
renseignement à la suite d'un accord de
la cntr l'accord a été donné pour une
finalité se précise et donner et nous
considérons que l'équilibré actuel n'est
pas bon dans la mesure où si une fois
qu'il a été obtenu avec un accord pour
une finalité donné il peut circuler sans
le même niveau de contrôle alors il n'ya
pas le bon équilibre et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous proposons que dans ce
cadre les transmissions entre services
soient aussi soumises au contrôle de la
scène c'était merci amendements
présentés par monsieur benarroch
je vais compléter juste que vient de
dire monsieur le comte en ce qui
concerne la transmission donc de
services à nos des données de
renseignements collectés
il est regrettable effectivement que la
vie de la cntr ne soit pas un avis
conforme au regard des tactiques
utilisées particulièrement intrusif
il est essentiel qu'une autorité
indépendante dans un avis contraignant
la cnil d'ailleurs à souligner cette
nécessité renforcer le contrôle de la
cnct air afin de le rendre effectif est
primordial pour qu'elles dépassent un
rôle de faire valoir des décisions de
l'exécutif compte tenu du caractère
extrêmement attentatoires aux libertés à
la vie privée des pouvoirs qui serait
donnée aux services des garanties
doivent être prévus afin de protéger les
libertés individuelles de nos
concitoyens c'est pour cela que nous
souhaitons
de l'avis de l'ancien ctr conforme à
merci et puis l'amendement 19 secondes à
mal sa psy merci monsieur le président
je m'inscris dans les propos qu'il y à
une d'être dit mieux et je les prolonge
simplement pour rappeler que la cnil
à propos des dispositions de cet article
avait relevé qu'elles permettent donc
formellement au premier ministre
d'autoriser la mise en oeuvre immédiate
d'une technique de renseignement même
après un avis défavorable de la sntr
elle remonte elle recommande donc qu'il
soit sauf dans certains cas d'urgence
absolue interdit au premier ministre
d'autoriser la mise en oeuvre d'une
technique de renseignement après un avis
défavorable de la cndc terre je voudrais
appris aussi que le conseil d'état avait
exigé dans son arrêt du 21 avril 2021 je
cite un contrôle près à la pour par une
autorité administrative indépendante
dotée d'un pouvoir d'avis conforme ou
une juridiction est en outre la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme la cdh
avait rendu le 25 mai un arrêté big
brother watch contre royaume uni où elle
exige que les activités d'interception
en masse soit soumise à l'autorisation
d'une autorité indépendante dès le
départ dès la définition de l'objet et
de l'étendue de l'opération est donc en
suivant toutes ces recommandations nous
proposons donc ce que soit inscrit dans
la loi
l'exigence d'un avis conforme de la cntr
merci habile la commission sur ces trois
amendements madame la rapportera sur
l'amendement 6 de monsieur le comte qui
disent à subordonner toute transmission
de services de renseignement une
autorisation du premier ministre après
avis de la scène ctr les contraire à la
position que nous avons déjà eu en en
première lecture puisque on considère
que l'article 7 justement assure un
équilibre entre les renseignements qui
sont bruts et qui pourrait poursuivre
des finalités différentes de celles qui
ont justifié le recueil et les
renseignements qui sont transmis car
issu d'une technique de renseignements
qu'elle le destinataire n'avaient pas
accès sur l'amendement un numéro 3 sera
aussi un avis défavorable car nous
pensons que il est satisfait dans
l'esprit puisque en vertu de l'article
16 6 points livre délivre une
autorisation contre l'avis de la cntr
alors le conseil d'état etc
immédiatement saisi et même raisonnement
et même avis défavorable pour
l'amendement numéro 19
merci à ville de du gouvernement madame
la ministre sur ces trois amendements
oui merci monsieur le président
brièvement et pour justifier les avis du
gouvernement en ce qui concerne
l'amendement numéro 6 de monsieur le
sénateur leconte nous considérons qu'il
convient de préserver les équilibres du
texte qui a été adopté par l'assemblée
nationale et la commission des lois du
sénat est de concilier donc le droit à
la vie privée et l'efficacité
opérationnelle et je voudrais rappeler
que seront soumises à autorisation
préalable du premier ministre délivré
après l'avis de la cnc terre les
transmissions de renseignement dit brut
motivé par une finalité différentes de
celles ayant justifié la mesure de
surveillance mais il en ira aussi de
même pour les transmissions de
renseignement brut mais aussi transcrit
ou extraits dans tous les cas où le
service sa destinataire n'aurait pas pu
mettre en oeuvre lui même la mesure de
surveillance et le verrou que constitue
cette procédure en force et se justifie
nous semble-t-il pleinement en ce qui
concerne l'amendement à 19 qui était
initialement déposée par madame la
sénatrice à celle ci je veux dire que
l'article 7 ne concerne que la question
de la transmission de renseignements
entre services et entre l'administration
et ces mêmes services et non pas le
principe même de mise en oeuvre d'une
technique de renseignement et concernant
l'amendement numéro 3 de monsieur
benarroch je veux rappeler qu'à la
différence de la mise en oeuvre de
certaines techniques de renseignement
les échanges d'informations entre les
services échappe totalement au droit de
l'union européenne puisque les exigences
posées par le conseil d'état au titre de
l'application du droit de l'union
européenne en ce qui concerne les
différentes prérogatives notamment de la
cntr et la portée de son avis non pas
être transposée au stade de ces échanges
je crois me souvenir que nous avions
déjà évoqué cette question précédemment
donc c'est aussi un avis défavorable
bien donc nous avons un double avis
défavorable sur ces trois amendements je
vais les soumettre ou voit d'abord
l'amendement numéro 6 qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté
l'amendement numéro 3 qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient n'est pas adoptée
même vote sur le 19 mai mme vote donc
les amendements ne sont pas adoptées
amendement numéro 7 monsieur le comte
oui monsieur le président nous
considérons que les services de
renseignements ne sont pas un service
des archives et que par conséquent s'ils
ont besoin d'information qu'ils vont
chercher auprès d'administrations qui
sont titulaires d'informations qui sont
couverts par un secret professionnel il
conviait hier qu'elle les utilise dans
un délai court puisque finalement les
services de renseignement doivent agir
et agir en fonction de la situation mais
rapidement et donc si ils vont chercher
des informations sensibles auprès d'une
autre administration
il conviendrait qui les utilisent
rapidement sinon ils sont plus dans leur
rôle c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
proposons que lorsqu'ils font appel à ce
type de renseignements qui sont
sensibles et qui sont obtenues auprès
d'autres administrations
ils doivent être détruits après six mois
parce qu'en fait il faut qu'il soit
utilisé rapidement s'ils ont une vraie
utilité ils ne sont pas là pour les pour
constituer une deuxième administration
qui conserverait
des dizaines et des dizaines
d'informations sensibles qui ne sont pas
de leur ressort
merci à vis de la commission oui merci
monsieur le président ce sera un avis
défavorable
d'une part parce que je rappelle que
l'article 7 tel qu'il a été modifié
prévoit dorénavant les renseignements
transmis par les autorités
administratives ne sont qu'à
l'initiative de celle ci d'une part
d'autre part quand les renseignements
sont trente filles peuvent être brut et
dans ces cas là la destruction peut être
inférieur au délai de six mois que vous
proposez puisqu'ils n'ont plus d'utilité
et par contre d'autres renseignements
peuvent être conservés pour une durée
plus longue parce qu'ils sont
intéressants et qu'ils sont encore
nécessaires à la mission de
renseignement donc ce sera un avis
défavorable
madame la ministre est défavorable
monsieur le président bien merci donc un
double avis défavorable sur cet
amendement je le soumets aux voies à
quai pour qui contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté l'amendement numéro 9
monsieur vaugrenard merci monsieur le
président je pourrais si vous en êtes
d'accord défendre les trois amendements
en même temps allez-y à la même logique
merci donc l'amendement numéro 9 il
s'agit de deux la question importante
qui va devenir je crois que crucial sur
le contrôle a posteriori des services de
renseignement français avec les services
de renseignement étrangers
je rappelle que le président de la
république lors d'un discours devant le
collège du renseignement en europe le 5
mars 2010neuf voici un peu plus de deux
années
c'est n'est que dans notre pays les
coopération entre services sont parfois
inconnus des décideurs eux-mêmes
c'est-à-dire des politiques eux mêmes
en conséquence nous suggérons que le
premier ministre fixe des orientations
relatives aux échanges entre les
services spécialisés de renseignement et
des services étrangers ou des organismes
internationaux
c'est le premier amendement donc le
moment numéro 9
l'amendement numéro 10 c'est dans le
prolongement de
demant précédent et
il apparaît donc judicieux dans ce
cadre-là d'étendre les compétences de la
commission nationale de contrôle des
techniques de renseignement qui pourra
ainsi contrôler tout simplement le
respect des orientations qui auront été
prises par le premier ministre et qui
remettrait un rapport annuel à la
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement relative donc aux échanges
entre les services français et les
services étrangers
l'amendement suivant donc l'amendement
numéro 8
si les deux amendements précédent ne
passe pas j'ose espérer que le troisième
aura peut-être quelques chances
concernant les échanges axés services
étrangers les gouvernements remettrait
suggérons que le gouvernement remette un
rapport avant le 31 décembre de l'an
prochain et 2022 afin de travailler sur
la définition d'un cadre légal sur ces
échanges
et sur ces échanges et de se conformer
aux exigences européennes
je rappelle que la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme à statuer sur cette
question l'un que notre pays risque
d'être condamné le fait qu'il ya pas de
contrôle a posteriori entre les services
français et les services de
renseignements étrangers et donc il
n'est pas urgent d'attendre dans ce
cadre là nous sommes le seul pays
européen à ne pas avoir une autorité de
contrôle a posteriori sur les échanges
entre ses différents services
il serait regrettable que tel pas
prendre de décision de ne pas réfléchir
un minimum d'orientation avant que notre
pays soit condamnée par la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme je vous
remercie
merci monsieur vaugrenard donc l'avis de
la commission sur ces trois amours merci
monsieur le président la question
soulevée par notre collègue vaugrenard
et est une vraie question dont l'enjeu
est est essentiel c'est celui des
échanges avec les services de
renseignement étrangers c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous pensons que nous ne
pouvons pas légiférer sur cette question
d'ampleur par simple voie d'amendement
et qu'il faut une réflexion plus
importante sous le contrôle du président
de la délégation parlementaire au
renseignement
cette dernière va s'emparer de ce sujet
et mettre en place une réflexion pour
effectivement pouvoir alimenter un
travail législatif futur c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous vous proposons pour
l'article 9-1 retrait
ou un avis défavorable idem pour
l'article 10 pour l'amendement 10 pardon
donc pour l'amendement 9 et pour
l'avènement du retrait ou avis
défavorable et pour l'amendement 8 si tu
te demandes de rapports et la dpr sera
amené à rendre ce rapport donc ton
pensons aussi qu'il sera satisfait donc
là aussi une demande de retrait ou
défavorable madame la ministre à vis du
gouvernement
merci monsieur le président ce sont
aussi des demandes de retrait pour le
gouvernement
je reviens pas sur le réglementaire
exposé a précédemment mais je veux
vraiment rappeler que l'article 7 que
nous sommes en train d'examiner porte
uniquement sur les échanges
d'informations entre services de
renseignement français ainsi qu'entre
ces administrations et ses services et
c'est tout je remercie bien merci donc
qu'il y a dont trois avis défavorable
des de la commission et du gouvernement
donc je vais les soumettre aux voix qui
est pour l'amendement numéro 9
il y avait une demande de prise de
parole monsieur richard excusez moi je
dis de façon sobre
je pense que la présentation café ya les
pros beaugrenelle vaugrenard tout à
l'heure de la méconnaissance par les
autorités politiques des mécanismes
d'échangé coopération entre services est
un peu réductrice me semble qu'il ya
beaucoup de moyens de s'assurer que ces
échanges et ses coopérations qui sont la
plupart du temps bilatérale sur la base
d'une expérience du travail partagé son
bien sous le contrôle du cac à la
connaissance des autorités politiques
bien donc je reviens au vote donc qui
est pour l'amendement numéro 9
les contres qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopté l'amendement numéro 10 même vote
l'amendement numéro 8 je le soumets on
voit qui est pour les contres qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté je mets
aux voix l'article 7 qui et pour qui les
contres qui s'abstient il est adopté
nous passons à l'article 11 avec un
amendement manama ça si la moniale
numéro 17
oui merci monsieur le président avec cet
amendement nous voulons réaffirmer notre
opposition à l'expérimentation pour une
durée de quatre ans de l'interception
des communications au printemps laboual
satellitaire d'une part
l'expérimentation de cette nouvelle
technique risque d'engendrer le recueil
d'informations qui ne concerne pas la
mesure ni la prévention d'actes des
terroristes étant donné le champ
d'interception de communications rendu
possible nous estimons en effet que cet
article ne présentent pas de garanties
suffisantes empêchant le recueil de
données sensibles et personnelles de
citoyennes et citoyens qui ne seraient
pas visés par l'interception de
conversations mais subirait une
violation de leur vie intime en effet le
recueil de ces données est prévu dans un
périmètre qui intercepterait des
renseignements élargies à toutes et tous
sans distinction
la mise en oeuvre de mesures de filtrage
en amont pour empêcher toute intrusion
intrusion serait plus respectueuse de la
vie privée des personnes qui ne sont pas
concernés par la recherche de
renseignements
nous ne sommes pas forcément opposé à
une expérimentation de cette technique
dans le seul cadre de la prévention
d'actes théorie je tiens à le réaffirmer
mais nous vous alertons sur le risque
d'intrusion trop important au détriment
du respect de la vie privée le manque de
mesures préventives pour empêcher toute
atteinte de ce type est inquiétant
pourquoi ne pas prendre le temps
d'affiner l'expérimentation de ce
dispositif pour qu'il n'en sort pas une
surveillance de masse qui
contreviendraient totalement à
l'objectif recherché et entraînerait une
inquiétude parmi la population
d'autre part il apparaît évident que
cette expérimentation comme toutes les
autres avant elle en matière de
renseignement et sécurité intérieure
finira par être pérennisée car comme
l'expriment l'observatoire des libertés
du numérique je cite il n'y a jamais de
retour en arrière sur les
expérimentations et mesures liberticides
mise en place aucun retour plus
favorable aux libertés incitations et ce
quand bien même des demandes légitimes
et mesurés sur l'état vend ces
augmentations des pouvoirs de la cntr
contrôle des échanges avec des services
étrangers réel pouvoir de contrôle
parlementaire réelle possibilité de
contestation individuelle et j'espère
que vous avez compris le sens de mon
intervention et de la raison pour
laquelle vous demandons la suppression
de cet article
merci à vivre la commission d'amm là
pour tous ces présidents amendement de
suppression avis défavorable madame la
ministre monsieur président bien donc un
double avis défavorable qui est pour cet
amendement qui les contres qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 12
monsieur le comte le président un
islamiste et jacques collègues nous
proposons par cet amendement de rétablir
la rédaction du sénat en première
lecture dans la mesure où nous
considérons que compte tenu de l'état
des techniques d'interception des
correspondances par voie satellitaire
il est plus prudent au début de
s'assurer de permettre exclusivement au
service du premier cercle de disposer et
d'utiliser ces techniques qui sont des
techniques qui démarre et qu'il est
préférable de laisser aux services qui
ont le plus de capacités techniques de
le faire de manière robuste et sans
risque c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous tenons à la rédaction
qui a été adopté en première lecture et
que nous proposons c'est son retour
merci à vis de la commission demande de
retrait ou avis défavorable nous pensons
que l'accord qui a été trouvé les
précisions qui ont été portées par
l'international sur la limitation des
services du second cercle qui sont
concernés par ces expérimentations
satellitaire est un équilibre au final
satisfaisant et qui concerne j'attends
vraiment qui correspond pardon vraiment
attendre des services donc avis retrait
ou avis défavorable madame la ministre
est favorable mais surprise on vient
donc un double avis défavorable je
soumets l'amendement vote qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 11 sur l'eau compte
également défendu comme la rapporteure
c'est président demande de retrait ou
avis défavorable car nous pensons que
l'article l 1111 3 du code de la
sécurité intérieure prévoit déjà des
finalités pour cette technique de
renseignements madame le ministre dit
favorable sur tristan donc un double
avis défavorable je soumets l'amendement
numéro on voit qui pour qui contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée je
soumets au voile article 11 qui au pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient un article
11 est adopté article 13
l'amendement numéro 18 madame grès au
par cet amendement nous nous opposons à
l'extension de la portée des boîtes
noires au delà des données de connexion
pourra intégrer des adresses complètes
de ressources utilisées sur internet
soit les urls je souhaitais ici rappeler
notre ferme opposition à la
pérennisation de ces boîtes noires dont
l'extension est ici enquêtrice sans
aucun argument précis ni information
chiffrée
sans prendre en compte l'avertissement
du conseil d'état qui note que cette
extension ouvre un champ nouveau
d'investigation potentiellement
attentatoires la protection de la vie
privée et des données personnelles mais
qui juge
partie retient la disposition et en
ignorant la décision du conseil quantis
constitutionnelle du 23 juillet 2015 ou
le conseil avait validé les boîtes
noires en prenant en compte la
possibilité qu'elle traite le contenu
des correspondances échangées ou d
informations consultez sous quelque
forme que ce soit dans le cadre de ses
communications
or ces url adresse selon des
informations consultées sont des
informations consultez pardon enfin la
cnil estime que le rock avec des url et
susceptibles de faire apparaître des
informations relatives au contenu des
éléments consulter ou aux
correspondances échangées qui ne
respecteraient pas la vie privée de la
personne
exemple l'orientation sexuelle est
absente et c'est finalement l'extension
des données traitées par les algorithmes
aux adresses internet complète étend le
champ d'investigation et par conséquent
à plein apparaît plus attentatoires à la
protection de la vie privée et des
données personnelles
pour toutes ces raisons et par cohérence
avec l'amendement de suppression déposé
à l'article 12 nous souhaitons supprimer
cet article 13 qui pérennise la mise en
oeuvre des boîtes noires sans faire le
bilan auprès des parlementaires
ce que prévoyait pourtant la loi du 24
juillet 2015 avant la date du 30 juin
2021 merci madame avis de la commission
merci monsieur le président ce sera un
avis défavorable c'est un amendement de
suppression de l'extension des
algorithmes aux url
nous pensons nous au contraire que
d'abord la pérennisation des algorithmes
et nécessaire est hautement d'autre part
son extension du réel prometteur mais
néanmoins doit être soumis un certain
nombre de contrôles c'est pour ça que
nous préférions que ce soit une
expérimentation que nous avons rétabli
dans ce texte
merci à vis du gouvernement madame la
ministre
mais magie monsieur le président mais ma
vie donc un double avis défavorable je
soumets l'amendement 18 on voit qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
n'est pas adopté l'amendement 5 monsieur
le comte la ministre mes chers collègues
c est un amendement de précision dans la
mesure où lorsqu'on dit en étant les
algorithmes aux url on comprend bien
entendu conte des temps les algorithmes
aux hypertexte qui sont utilisés ce pour
se connecter sur sur une sur une page de
données
toutefois nous souhaitons précisément
exclus des algorithmes les éventuels
hypertexte qui seraient contenues dans
de la correspondance ou dans le le le la
page internet ou dans le sms qui serait
qu il serait envoyé
voilà c'est donc un amendement de
précision qui nous sont très importants
pour cadrer effectivement le fonctionnel
la plage de d2 des algorithmes et la
capacité des algorithmes de ce que les
algorithmes je peux prendre en compte
bien merci
habib de la commission merci monsieur
président sera un avis défavorable nous
avons déjà eu ce débat en première
lecture et le gouvernement nous avait
apporté les garanties nécessaires
un bis du gouvernement madame la
ministre
oui exactement monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur nous avions déjà eu
ce débat est au demeurant aucune donnée
dans les correspondances électroniques
aucune donnée quelle qu'elle soit et
donc même les url ne peut être traité
par les algorithmes
on craindrait même que ça puisse être
contre productif sa version mentionnent
que les url dans les courriers
électroniques ne peuvent pas être
traitées par les algorithmes
ça pourrait même sous entendre que le
reste de l'intérieur des données des
courriers électroniques pourrait l'être
ce qui n'est pas le cas à l'heure
actuelle dans le projet de loi donc pour
nous c'est vraiment déjà satisfait très
clairement donc une demande de redon
qu'un double avis défavorable je soumets
l'amendement voix qui est pour et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée je
soumets ou voix l'article 13 qui est
pour et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté l'article 15
je me vois l'article 15 qui et pour qui
les contres qui s'abstient
il est adopté l'article 16 bis même vote
l'article 17 même vote est adoptée à
l'article 17 bis amendement de monsieur
vaugrenard l'amendement numéro 13 oui
merci monsieur le président madame la
reporter madame la ministre
il est essentiel pour la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement de
disposer tous les ans d'un bilan des
recommandations adressées par la
commission nationale de contrôle des
techniques du renseignement à l'exécutif
en leur qualité de législateurs eurent
gardent leur mission de contrôle de la
politique publique du renseignement les
membres de la dpr doit disposer de ces
éléments pour savoir si des
contournements encadrent juridiques
qu'ils ont posées ont été constatés afin
le cas échéant d'apporter les
modifications législatives qu'il serait
nécessaire de porter je vous remercie
merci à vis de la commission ce sera une
demande de retrait ou un avis
défavorable nous avons déjà eu ce débat
en première lecture
nous pensons que il faut veiller à ce
que la dpr ne soit pas destinataire de
l'information sur des opérations en
cours ou des opérations précise c'est la
raison pour laquelle l'article 16 bis et
un amendement de compromis sur le rôle
de la dpr et qui nous paraît pas
opportun d'y ajouter ces précisions
habits du gouvernement madame manon bien
donc nous avons un double avis
défavorable je soumets l'amendement
trait aux voix qui pourront qui contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement numéro 4 monsieur benarroch
mais c'est le président c'est un
amendement qui porte sur la composition
du dpr et qui est inspiré du travail
mené sur le sujet un serbe et nationales
pour modifier dans la composition de la
direction de la délégation parlementaire
au renseignement et a renforcé ses
prérogatives
la dpr n'est actuellement proposé que de
quatre députés et quatre sénateurs dont
les présidents des commissions
permanentes chargé des affaires de
sécurité intérieure et de défense qui en
sont membres de droit par le présent
amendement nous souhaitons d'un cran
c'est son effectif et le porter de 8 à
20 membres afin d'accroître le
pluralisme politique de cet organe est
de permettre la représentation des
groupes minoritaires et de l'opposition
pour gagner en effectivité
la délégation parlementaire au
renseignement doit également disposer
d'un pouvoir d'injonction renforcer et
être en mesure de donner des
instructions générales ou services de
renseignement tel est l'objet du présent
amendement
merci avis de la commission c'est un
avis défavorable à des pairs à une
constitution qui est source d' équilibre
d'une part et d'autre part la
possibilité de donner des instructions
aux services de renseignement et crainte
contraire au principe de séparation des
pouvoirs
madame la ministre défavorable donc un
double avis défavorable je soumets
l'amendement aux voix qui est pour et
qui est contre
il s'abstient n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 14 monsieur vaugrenard
merci monsieur le président voici six
ans le parlement avait prévu une
disposition particulière permettant un
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement d'auditionner chaque
semestre
le premier ministre sur l'application
des dispositions de la loi
renseignements 2015 en première lecture
donc l'assemblée nationale a supprimé
ses disposition considérant qu'elle
était obsolète ce qu'on peut entendre
néanmoins il serait utile de la
remplacer par une audition annuelle du
premier ministre sur le réexamen
périodique de l'état de la menace qui
sous-tend le maintien de la conservation
généralisée des données de connexion
comme l'existant comme l'exigent pardon
du reste la cour européenne de justice
et le conseil d'état en effet est
important qu'un contrôle parlementaire
puisse exercer sur le sujet et que
l'exécutif motive sa position à ce titre
il est donc proposé que la dpr seule
instance bicaméral habilité à connaître
d'informations classifiées ses membres
sur secrétariat être habilité au niveau
secret défense puis s'enquérir de
l'évolution de la menace allocation à
l'occasion d'une audition annuelle du
chef du gouvernement
couvert par le secret de la défense
nationale merci chers collègues avis de
la commission
merci monsieur président demande de
retrait ou avis défavorable à des pères
peut déjà auditionné le premier ministre
quand elle le souhaite et exercé à vis
de contrôle madame la ministre mais
magie monsieur le président mais ma vie
donc un double avis défavorable je
soumets l'amendement voix qui est pour
et contre s'abstient il n'est pas
adoptée je soumets on voit l'article 17
bis qui et pour qui et contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté les autres
dispositions du projet de loi ne font
pas l'objet de la nouvelle lecture
je vais donc mettre aux voix l'ensemble
du projet de loi y at il des demandes
d'explications de vote
monsieur sua
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chaque collègue je ne reviendrai pas sur
les raisons qui nous conduisent à nous
abstenir sur ce texte et compte exposer
mes collègues jean yves le conte et
yannick vaugrenard
mais je tiens revenir dans cette
explication de vote
sur l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
nous ne pouvons pas voter ce texte vadam
la ministre c'est cette question des
archives
il n'était pas possible ce soir de
parler de l'article 19 qui a
malheureusement été adopté dans les
mêmes termes par les deux assemblées
mais je veux redire ici avec force nom
de notre groupe que cet article pose de
très considérable le problème d'abord
parce qu'il étend la possibilité de ne
pas délivrer des documents à quatre
domaines qui sont importants qui sont
vagues dans leur définition qui sont
larges et cela en contradiction de la
loi de 2008 qui avait l'avantagé d'être
très clair
à ce sujet et que nous avons voté comme
beaucoup d'entre vous mais chaque
collègue
ensuite il est prévu que le refus de
communication pour être perpétuelle pas
de limites c'est non et puisque c'est
non c'est non
et enfin il est prévu que pour certains
dispositifs ce sera toujours interdite
tant que le dispositif sera en opération
sera tout ça est très flou alors nous
voulons ici nous faire l'interprète à
nouveau de tous les universitaires de
tous les historiens notamment les
historiens de l'histoire contemporaine
de tous les archivistes qui nous sont
encore écrit aujourd'hui en me disant
mais fait quelque chose je vais vous
dire ce que nous allons faire comme nous
considérons qu'il ya là eu des atteintes
à des principes fondamentaux notamment
au droit l'histoire au droit à la
mémoire au droit de savoir et qu'il ya
beaucoup d'arbitraire contrairement à
l'amendement que nous avions posé il
fallait que ce soit exceptionnelle
justifiée pour dix ans et dans des cas
où il ya véritablement des intérêts et
des menaces graves sur notre pays nous
le comprenons très bien mais cela n'a
pas du tout été pris en compte et comme
il y à monsieur le président je conclus
des principes lourds qui sont en cause
nous saisirons le conseil
constitutionnel à cet égard merci n'y a
pas d'autre explication au vote
je suis j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe crc sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi
il va donc être procédé au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 du règlement le scrutin est
ouvert
bien plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
44 des exprimés deux cent soixante dix
huit pour 252 contre 26 le sénat a
adopté
[Musique]